Narrator: In the last
video we took a look at
what is probably the
simplest possible economy
and it's not even clear
that this economy is
even possible; this one person economy.
To make it more analogous
to the real world
where we have household and we have firms.
In this one island this guy set up a firm
and he essentially leashed
out all of the factors
of production to that firm,
including his own labor.
He leased it out, the rent on his labor
is essentially his
wages and then he bought
all of the goods and services he needed
from that same firm.
So, his expenditures would be the revenue
of that firm and then
the revenue of that firm
would be turned into the expenses
and the profit of the
firm, so whatever the
revenue wasn't used in expenses ended up
being profit.
Then all of that went back to that one
household as income.
When we talked about how we would measure
the economic activity in this island
right over here, how would we measure its
gross domestic product, we said,
well look we could measure it in multiple
different ways.
As it's leaving his
hands, the dollars that is
going to the firm, you
could view it as the
total expenditures, or as it's approaching
the firm that's the
same thing as the total
revenue for this firm,
total revenue for this
simplified, one firm economy.
That total revenue is
the same thing as the
total expenses plus the
profit for that firm.
That's the same thing as this one
households income.
So, let me write this down.
The way we looked at it in the last video,
in the very simple
example, GDP was equal to
household, household
expenditures which was equal
to firm, firm revenues
which was equal to firm
expenses, expenses plus profit,
which is equal to household income.
(writing) household income, household ..
I'll just write inc for
income, household income.
and of course household income is then,
at least in this case right over here,
it ended up being equal
to household expenses.
What I want to do in this video now is
think about it in more general terms.
Let's extend it to a more complex economy,
to the world we live in and
with that I want to look
at the more formal definition for GDP.
This is the more formal definition of GDP,
or I guess you could say
the definition of GDP
and it's the market
value of all final goods
and services, and we're
going to talk about what
each of these things
mean ... of all, of all
final goods and services.
I'll underline all
separately, all final goods
and services.
Let me do that in a different color.
... all final goods and
services produced within
a country, produced within a country
in a given period.
You can have a GDP for a month,
you could have a GDP
for a quarter of a year
which would be three
months or you could have
the GDP in a given year.
I guess you could even have GDP over a
10 year period, but it tends to be
we always think of GDP
in terms of annual GDP
or quarterly GDP or sometimes even ...
so there are some estimates
of even monthly GDP
but it tends to be annually or quarterly.
Let's parse a little
bit more because these
little terms can be interesting.
The first one I'd like
to parse is the idea of
market value.
(writing) Market value.
What this is saying is we
need someway to measure
what we've produced
and the best way we can
do it is say, how much
benefit are people getting
and what they're willing
to pay for it in the
market is the best way that we can measure
how much benefit they're actually getting
out of it.
For example, if someone in the year,
I don't know, if an avocado was produced,
if an avocado is produced in some farm
and also an orange is produced,
and an orange is produced,
we won't say that for each of these,
we won't say, oh GDP is
increased to buy one fruit
we'd look at the market value for it.
If the market value of this avocado is
$1 and the market value of
this orange is 0.50 cents
then by producing this fruit the GDP has
increased by 0.50 cents by producing this
avocado its GDP has increased by a dollar.
In the next year, maybe there's whatever,
demand for avocado's goes down or whatever
and people pay less for
it and the market value
of an incremental avocado is 0.50 cents,
then in the next year
even though the actual
number of fruit that
was produced is the same
as the previous year, now all of a sudden
the contribution from
avocado's might be the same
as a contribution from oranges.
It really depends on the market value.
Then we can focus on this
all, the market value of all
goods and services,
all goods and services.
We would do all the different avocado's
and oranges, but we would do computers,
we would do cars, we would do tires,
and we're doing services,
so if you have help
at home, if you go to the doctor;
the market value of all of
those things are going to
be put in to GDP.
This won't include some things.
This does not include,
this does not include
illegal things.
If someone sells someone else drugs
we're not keeping track of it.
Some would argue that maybe it should be
kept track of in some
way, that you have this
kind of black market in things,
but you're not keeping track of illegal,
(writing) illegal activity.
And you're also not keeping track of goods
and services that are produced within
the household and consumed
within the household.
For example, if you hire an outside person
to babysit your child
that would be considered
part of GDP, that is
a service that you are
paying for, but if you,
yourself, are babysitting
your children that is not
going to be considered
in GDP.
If I start a lawn-mowing business
and I go mow other people's lawns,
or maybe before my wife and I were dating,
she used to pay me to mow my lawns
then it would be included in GDP,
but maybe once we get
married I just mow her lawn
because we're in the same family now
then it will not be included in GDP.
All does include pretty
much everything that
can be tracked, anything where there is an
exchange of money, there's some payment
between two parties for
that good or service.
Now a really interesting thing
and this is something I
used to find confusing
when I first got exposed to GDP,
is the whole notion of
final goods and services.
To understand this, let's think about,
let's think about how
jeans might be produced.
You have a cotton farmer, a cotton farmer
and there's some service
that needs to be performed
so whatever some farming,
some labor that needs
to be performed.
Let's say that that is $5 of labor
and let's say that some
land has to be rented.
Let's say that that is $5
of ... I'll just make it
a different number, $4 of land.
(writing) $4 of land.
There are other inputs,
but we don't have to
go into all the details.
With that, there's going
to be some electricity
and things like that, but
we won't count all of it.
You can produce some cotton,
just the plant cotton.
(writing) you can produce,
you can produce some
cotton, some raw cotton.
That raw cotton is worth,
the market value of that
raw cotton is worth,
let's say it's worth $10.
So, it's $10 worth of raw cotton.
Then you can take that raw cotton
and you could combine
it with some more labor
(writing) with some more labor
so let's say you combine
that with another,
I don't know, $6 of labor.
(writing) $6 of labor
and it would also probably require some
machinery and electricity
and things like that,
but I won't factor all of
those things in just now.
We don't need them to
get the point across.
If I do that, if I combine the $10,
this intermediate good
with the $6 of labor
then all of a sudden I
can produce cotton thread.
(writing) I can produce, I
That cotton, the worth of the market value
of that cotton thread
let's say is now $20.
(writing) is now $20
And maybe there is another
intermediate good there,
maybe it's some dye.
We'll put the dye in
later, let's do the dye
in later.
I have a $20 thread,
and let's say I can take
that $20 thread.
(writing) I can take that $20 thread,
stay with white just
because I started there.
I can take that $20
thread and I can put in
some more labor, maybe
I can take $10 of labor
(writing) $10 of labor
and then I can essentially create,
it will essentially create $30 worth of,
$30 of cotton fabric.
(writing) $30 worth of cotton fabric.
Then I can take that $30
worth of cotton fabric
(writing) $30 worth of cotton fabric
plus some more labor, let's
say another $5 of labor.
(writing) $5 of labor
and let's say we're also going to put in
$1 of dye.
(writing) $1 of dye right over here.
In the process I can create,
I can create the market value,
let's say this is $50 worth of blue jeans.
(writing) $50 worth, worth of, blue jeans,
blue jeans.
I do this all over the course of the year,
so the period in question.
So the period for this
one I'll assume the period
is a year, so it's all
happening over the course
of the period in question.
We're talking about the GDP in 2012,
this is all happening in 2012.
What would be the contribution to GDP.
If we didn't have the word final here,
we just had the market value of all goods
and services then we would add this $5
to this $4 to this $10 to this $6
and because of the
production of this jeans
we would get a very, very large number,
a very, very large contribution to GDP.
But that would be, not
even double counting
that would be triple, or quadrupling,
or quintuple counting
the value that's actually
being created because all of this value
is essentially being
created for in this end $50.
The actual contribution
to GDP you would only put
the final good, so you
wouldn't include all of these
other intermediary goods and services,
you would just say this
whole chain of event
results in a $50 increase in GDP.
In another video we'll
talk about what happens
if they don't get to this
point during the course
of the year, if we just stop at one of the
intermediary goods.
Assuming you get to this
point, you just include
the final good in GDP.
This last part of it is,
produced within a country.
(writing) produced within a country.
This is, you might have heard GNP,
gross national product and that's the
main difference.
GDP says, let's say
we're talking about the
United States, that's my best attempt at
drawing the United States.
GDP says look, if it was produced inside
the country, if it was
produced inside the country,
we don't care who it was produced by.
It could have been
produced by someone from
Mexico, or it could have been produced by
someone from Canada, it
could have been a factory
that's owned by the Chinese, but if it was
produced within the borders
of the United States
it gets counted as GDP.
(writing) It gets counted as GDP.
If an American, if an American who's an
American national goes overseas
and produces something,
that is not counted
as GDP.
If an American owns a
firm in another country
and that firm in the
other country produces
something, that is not the GDP.
When you focus on peoples' nationality
that is GNP.
Not to confuse things,
but if you wanted to
focus on GNP then you do
care about the earnings
of American nationals and so you wouldn't
count the Canadian, but you would include
the American who's making money overseas.
GDP fairly simple idea,
you say what's being
produced within these boundaries,
we don't care who's doing the producing
and what their actual nationality is,
and we're going to ignore production by
that nationality outside of these borders.